okay big breaking news story according
to the Kremlin Donald Trump has invited
Vladimir Putin to the White House and
you might say well who cares we should
want better relationships with Russia we
should want to be Russia's friend this
is great yay and then we get back to
reality
and we learned that this reportedly
happened during that same phone call a
couple of weeks ago where after being
told do not congratulate Vladimir Putin
on his sham election win Donald Trump
did exactly that congratulated Vladimir
Putin on his win mentioned nothing about
election meddling mentioned nothing
about the continued suspicious deaths of
Russian dissidents around the world and
the claim about this invitation to maybe
come to the White House for Vladimir
Putin came from a Kremlin aide named
Yuri ochakov who said that Russian who
said to Russian journalists that quote
if everything will be alright I hope
that the Americans will not back away
from their own proposal to discuss the
possibility of holding a summit when our
president spoke on the phone it was
Trump who proposed holding the first
meeting in Washington in the White House
Putin hasn't been to the White House
since 2005 when george w bush was
president when the US and russia i guess
sort of had a better relationship you
could say so why do we care well we care
because this is Vladimir Putin's
manipulation of Donald Trump bearing
fruit right it's another example of
Putin getting what he wants which is be
being seen as a sort of serious world
leader that gets invited and the red
carpet is rolled out for them and they
get to go into the most special of
places although certainly the white the
Oval Office has become less special
since Donald Trump has appropriated it
what better situation for Putin than a
long in-person meeting with Trump on
Trump's own turf were Putin who is very
skilled will use his skills to
manipulate Trump and even even when you
look at how we found out about this
right even the release of this news by
Russia is part of the ploy to embarrass
Trump
just create chaos because now it's
win-win for Vladimir Putin if trump
admits yeah III did say that he could
come to the White House well why wasn't
it mentioned and why would Trump do it
and why would he reward Russia with
inviting Vladimir Putin to the White
House and then if Trump denies it it
immediately calls into question whether
Trump is lying something that he does a
lot and if so it would make us wonder
why is this something that Trump would
lie about which only increases more of
the suspicions about what's going on
with Russia the fact that we're first
hearing about this from Russia is sort
of part of the chaos that Russia is so
expertly catalyzing and we once again
we've got to apply Trump's razor to this
as I mentioned yesterday no matter what
you believe the limits of geopolitical
stupidity to be the current
administration the Trump administration
will act in the most ignorant and stupid
way possible to the point that you will
be shocked and in fact the most likely
scenario is that we get initially a
denial from the Trump administration
followed by a White House visit by
Vladimir Putin and then there will never
actually be a follow-up question about
wait I thought you'd deny that you had
invited him to him here the way it
always goes is is some version of that
right we hear from the Washington Post
or the New York Times something that
sounds totally nuts then you know Trump
uses his bathtub as a toilet or
something that sounds absolutely nutty
White House immediately condemned says
the president would never use his
bathtub as a toilet it's the fake news
media including that failing fake news
Amazon Jeff Bezos Washington Post
they're smearing the president then like
two days later Trump goes to Twitter and
says hey yeah alright I use my bathtub
as a toilet and Hillary was using her
bathtub as a toilet before I did and the
FBI refuses to look into when Hillary
Clinton is using her bathtub as a toilet
no one cares about that and I've been
treated very very unfairly and then the
sort of cherry on top is three days go
by and then Trump says why I never said
I used my bathtub as a toilet I was
misquoted by the loser new york time
I never said it and then a hundred grand
goes to another pornstar in hush money
and we all forget about it because we're
like ten scandals past it that is the
sort of mo of how these things develop
will we ever hear about it again I
genuinely doubt now the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership